well this is really the last thing
consumers want to hear during the winter
but energy prices are on the rise we're
talking more than 100 million people
under winter weather alerts and that
will lead to supply and demand issues
for natural gas as so many americans
will crank up the thermometer especially
this morning ted said it was near
freezing christian cassette spoke to
some local residents about the hike in
their bill they're not happy about it
they are not happy let me tell you many
southwest gas customers were taken back
by their bill some telling us their
monthly bill doubled or even tripled
their normal amount but their usage
didn't now southwest gas issued a
warning back in november about this
saying the cost for natural gas was
expected to go up this winter and it did
now the company says the increase is due
to the price of gas going up as well as
an increase in usage local residents
like ashley telling us the hike in price
made a big impact to her budget
it impacts it a lot
i'm facing some
employment challenges as many are right
now
and
not knowing really what your bill is
going to be any given month is pretty
challenging you don't know how to budget
accordingly
well there are some ways to help keep
the costs down southwest gas recommends
setting your daytime thermostat between
65 and 68 degrees and maybe lowering it
at night change and clean your air
filters on a regular base that also
helps and seal any cracks or leaks
around doors or windows it can
definitely keep some of that warm air
inside now a spokesperson for southwest
gas told us they understand customers
may be experiencing natural gas bill
higher than expected they are
encouraging customers to take advantage
of their equal payment plan we have
those details on our website
8newsnow.com christian cassette is live
local now